I see oh my name's Nicole I'm calling
from Houston Texas thank you for your
call Nicole onward I'm a stay-at-home
mom I have a young boy and I'm expecting
another young boy here in a few months
Oh congratulations he's gonna have a
brother you know that's pretty special
I'm thinking you know you can't really
plan a hell you can't really plan ahead
on a lot of that you know - um you know
I don't think you know as a parent maybe
you don't know what you're creating when
you make a brother for a kid but that
can be I mean there's no other
relationship like that so you know I
commend you on being brave enough to
have two children because you not only
you're creating you're gonna be creating
a relationship with you and your son
you're gonna be broadening your family
but you were giving a kid a brother and
there's nothing you know I can't explain
to you uh you know I'm fortunate enough
to have a brother and I can't explain to
you what that relationship is like it
hasn't always been great but it's just
so it's so great to have a brotherhood
to be able to to compare and navigate
how I'm supposed to behave towards other
men and how and have someone who already
is a little bit of a blueprint of myself
out there to look at and feed off of to
get ideas and Inklings for things and
get some advice and some suggestions so
you're really creating something awesome
so I commend you for that onward what
are some things that you as a man would
advise new moms to instill in their
young sons to be later good men does
that make sense I hope so
it does make sense if you know I think
spending time with them one on one as I
get a little bit older you know as they
get to be like five six seven eight
spend some time just separately go do
something separate with your son
my favorite time that I ever had when I
was young was when the power went out
and my family would all be together and
we couldn't fight or beat each other
because they had candles lit and it's
dangerous to beat each other
candles so we would just be together and
we were kind of scared and nervous but
we were all together like in one place
you know my mom had two candles and so
we would have to be by her and we would
have to be together and it was just I
don't know it was something special
about that oh that's my brother
what's up Z Hey all right dude don't
tell me what happened no no I didn't
look do not tell me well that's why I
didn't that I wouldn't tell you anything
hey don't tell me no actually this is a
perfect ending cuz I'm just finishing on
my podcast is the very end and I don't
know what happened I paused it right
after the Saints kicked their field goal
there was 25 seconds left and you're on
the podcast now and I can take this off
later if you want but but why don't you
tell me what happened I want to know
well yeah I mean now's the time to
notice is almost I mean I'm just
finishing the podcast is the perfect
time and we were just talking about a
Brotherhood and stuff Oh a minute ago so
this is kind of it's perfect I'm gonna
tell you about ten minutes about Who I
am
yeah well I was 10 seconds left to serve
ten or whatever they need about 20 yards
to get a field goal race 25 yards
anymore dad you know this is a one in a
hundred chance that the Saints lose 1%
yeah he threw it to Avon Diggs whoever's
name is do caught it like 40 right right
about probably four feet from the
sidelines Marcus Williams was right
there mmm-hmm my Holly has it was
literally pull him to the ground but for
some weird reason but Avon [ __ ] jumped
in the air Marcus Williams like job
underneath him I don't know what he was
doing I think he's trying to up in them
or something
mmm-hmm and when he doesn't even
momentum I mean clearly missed him beat
he rolled into the other quarterback all
knew it might even lead him on who it
was there
one day just ran in the ends oh no they
got a touchdown
yeah dude they were like on our 35 yeah
no in their own 35 or 40 second 1%
chance we had a lot we would lose that
game at that point a loss like that
similar to Tampa Bay but I didn't see
the end of the tape of a game but I'm
just gonna be harbouring yeah it was a
hard break man it really was because I
think we win that game we're down 17 to
nothing at the half
yeah I know I think we win going in
other way like a 30 40 percent shot and
we came back and really played really
well the seconds happened yeah you just
made such a weird play I don't know what
he was I really know what he was doing I
can't figure it out you know hoping
David gained him will I mean it was like
a last-ditch effort basically what it
was and I just don't see how yeah but it
happens you know it's over now it's over
I still can't believe it but it is over
but you have the weirdest stuff dude
damn man I know we had yeah I thought I
figured we had we have a really really
good shot here man
damn dude you out there boy um quick
question so actually we had a lady that
called in and she said what is something
she's about to have her second child and
she said what is something that that
mothers can do with their sons these
days to help make them better men and
it's kind of a question for mothers but
it's also a question for sons what do
you think is one thing a mother can do
with their children to make them better
man there's done yeah or something they
could talk to him instill in them I
don't know that I think it was it was a
little bit broad but yeah well you know
I don't know I thought you can do those
children are young to make them better
men when they get older
hmm for that some of the I don't know
some of the that male stuff to be Lerman
they're a little bit older when they're
young I think the best thing mother
could do is um
connect with emotionally connect with
their children of the emotionally
available yeah oh don't make sure that
the child knows that their behavior does
not determine your love for them even if
it makes you upset what they do when you
don't do and you can have another thing
you know is you can tell children early
on you can explain certain things to
them you might simplify it but they will
understand you right I don't got
enrolled you know up and telling them
I'm 4 year old where the six and five
now but we've since there were four so
mad at you it doesn't mean I don't love
you hmm what you do I love you
mmm now that's what you do may get you
in trouble but it has it's a love you
and then they understand it you know
yeah now that's my girls yeah my five
year old is now your madam you don't
love me don't say that max was like that
who say no it doesn't mean that it means
that I'm mad at you so you kind of you
know you just gotta help them along an
emotional availability and accept the
unconditional love is what they need I
mean that's you know what I'm like in
life that he's unconditional lover
Morris's father a parents house
especially mother child I mean they have
to be able to they have to know that you
love in the matter what they do if they
kill somebody when they're 8 or 10 I man
that say I'm just an extreme example you
know they got some young they got some
young hitters out there yeah the amount
you know the amount of your love is
should not waver now yeah because you're
the only place that can get that right
and you may choose not top simmer be
extremely disappointing I talk to them
for a year whatever but you know so that
thing it's real important you know cuz
sometimes in our society where our worth
is built on what we do what we don't do
and I think that a lot of that starts to
parent you know when the children yo
yeah you can fill that tank up early and
let them know that now that I get the
look man I I'll even just liked hearing
that you know that not what you know my
behavior if I would have heard that when
I was young I think I would have I might
be a little bit of a healthier person
today you know yeah let me - as you know
me - yeah
alright man well I appreciate you
calling I'm gonna call you later cuz I
got to run a literate to drive straight
to Brea right now I'm gonna just crash
love you day in love YouTube but that's
my brother Zephyr II know he lives down
and he lives in Baton Rouge Louisiana
but yeah it gets an interesting answer
he loved he really likes to think about
this kind of stuff and he loves to be a
parent and I mean his wife is a is a
stay-at-home mom and that's a CEO in my
book you know I mean if I could go back
in time and it's just coming a little
bit emotional but if I could go back in
time and have anything I would have that
you know I mean I can't even imagine
what that would be like you know to just
you know just be at home and be having
fun to be comfortable and have your mom
around you know so but anyhow I'll dude
you [ __ ] you guys have hit me in a
hot meet here at the end you know I had
a chance today to talk to my brother and
uh you know and I love my brother man I
used to not I used to never ever think
that I used to have really very little
feelings towards my brother except maybe
some anger just from not being around
when we were young but today I'm talking
to my brother and he's telling us some
problems that he's having you know some
stuff in his life and and it's real
stuff you know because he's he's pretty
fortunate in the fact that he's able to
solve some of the tertiary the smaller
items that are going on in his life but
he was talking about some real stuff and
I just listened to him you know I just
listened and then at the end I just told
him I loved him you know and I told him
I told him so I knew he meant so so he I
knew he knew that I meant it you know it
wasn't just kind of like an outlook
alright man love you you know you know I
knew that he just needed to hear it and
I guess I'm thankful for the fact that
that things can change in a relationship
you know that a leopard can't change its
spots it's one of the biggest lies in
the universe that a leopard can't change
its spots because years ago I would
never have done that I would have given
him some advice or some guidance not
knowing
anything like I do on this show and then
I would have just got off the phone with
them you know but this time I just knew
not to say anything just listen
sometimes people just need somebody to
listen so I guess I'm thankful that
today for one of the first times in my
life I felt like I was able to be a
brother you know like I was just able to
I didn't realize I was being one till
afterwards but we got done talking and I
was like well man you know I could tell
that he appreciated me being around and
that me he just appreciated having a
brother to talk to that's all a brother
is sometimes it's just two ears and a
heart that's all you got to be sometimes
you know hey Co this is Andrew from
Deadwood South Dakota anyway they have a
big party every st. Patty's Day and my
brother came down from college this past
weekend we went gambling and we went
partying and drinking no drug in but it
was really good to the head and seen him
in a while
oh that's nice I'm glad you got to spend
some time there with your with your
sibling more we got out during the day
with a beautiful day on Friday and we
went rock climbing in that damn y'all
active y'all Brotherhood is really
active my brother knob we barely get
over to the pizza hut more and then it
snowed a ton on Saturday and we damn and
this just starting to lead to romance
too you notice how a lot of these boys
be leading a row man let's hear more
thank you to go up snowboarding
Deadwood's up in the mountains of South
Dakota and so it's a really good time
and I really enjoyed seeing my brother
my dog just died and so I've been you
know kind of lonely I moved here by
myself and so it was a really really
special weekend just to kind of grow it
up and see him so oh man I appreciate
you calling the saying that day that's
nice I'm glad you and your brother got
to spend some time together man you know
you guys went rock climbing you went
snowboarding Jesus man and my brother
and I when did that one of our [ __ ]
legs would fall off and man it was nice
this weekend to see my brother
and uh and it's just something
man what a gift if you have a brother
you know to have somebody else that have
the same blood in them as you that is I
mean that's some Frankenstein style
shitake Gang Gang let's hear it here we
go hey Greg from Philly he was called in
about his brother living far away and
like 11 years apart he's in Texas he's
in Colorado and it's just tough to get
close and I thought I had something
maybe a little bit topical so yeah my
brother and I were like we look like
we're twins were real similar but I
don't know man like I have a lot of
trouble being close and I'm you know I
really wanted to get better with my
brother so I like moved in with him like
I'm living with a man right now okay so
if you're living with somebody then
that's that's a real move because that
is y'all could be damn husband but
you're already brothers so that'd be
crazy and they had a boy when I was
growing up named Eric slavich and
everybody said that his brother was his
father and we didn't never see any you
know pictures or anything but people did
sometime do drawings of you know his mom
doing some kind of wild [ __ ] homework
but it's so hard like there's always
difficulties with brothers I don't know
what it is like the genetic similarity
syncing up and repelling or some crazy
[ __ ] all right
oh what'd they say man two brothers
don't make a right say man is like tell
your brother you love them try to pick
something he's interested in like my
brother loves stand-up comedy you know
gives me to kill Logan
and two years later I'm looking to theof
on every Monday and Thursday and we
talked about comedy man it might be our
main or only similarities but it's
something dude that's what got a look at
it just got to try to find that one
connection one commonality Gang Gang
Gang man I'm glad you and your brother
have that experience I could sit there
laughs chuckle listen to things and do a
little bit of comedy
trying to think what my brother or not
like and that is a good suggestion fine
one thing it could be small like a
belittle you might like you know
throwing javelins or you know looking uh
you know looking for sinkholes or
something you know you guys might like
doing recipes or making a you know
making fun of magicians you might like
you know you might like gerbils you
might like baseball you might like
little Christmas trees and you know
doing little um origami with the wood
you know and you might like making
candles together or you know reading
about electricity to each other at night
doing you know bedtime stories or you
know drawing maps there's all types of
things you could enjoy but that is good
a suggestion to find a commonality let's
take another call that came in for the
young man with us some suggestions for
him over oh do what uh I'm calling about
the gentleman who was having trouble
connecting with his uh his brother of
eleven years you know one way that I've
always thought is a really a good way to
get close to my siblings one of them is
29-year there is 25 I am 21 myself so
sometimes it's hard to relate to them
you know they they live in different
states but something I always do is tell
them things that I would only tell my
best friend like secret ooh that's a
good one because if you tell a secret a
secret is basically just glue that's
coming out of your mouth a secret will
attach you to somebody you know a secret
I mean you put a secret in somebody you
got to [ __ ] know where they're at at
all times because they got you [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying let's hear more
like where I hid the peanut butter or
something like that you know so just
telling some deep dark secrets and that
usually helps you out so
oh yeah and I used to do [ __ ] like that
man I used to tell you no I remember
telling my you know one of my siblings
out one of my other siblings was you
know homoerotic and they weren't but for
like a year they thought they were and
so you know that's a secret it's not a
real secret but it's still a secret
I remember going on we went camping when
I was young or we were hiding from
something
I don't remember what it was but I told
everybody the second we left to go
camping I told everybody Jay Leno had
died and Jay Leno is a nighttime
comedian on television and I told
everybody that man that man died and the
truth was he didn't die but the whole
time we were camping people thought that
he was dead and so that's a secret so
the thing is you can just do a secret
but do it with your family that's it
tell them you've been [ __ ] eating you
know little fish or something swallowing
minnows you know because they will eat
out though you know probiotics that's in
your colon or something do something
start some fun at the house but that's a
good I believe in good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one watch
this one